CBS News chief Washington correspondent
and Face the Nation anchor that's John
Dickerson joins us at the table to
continue the discussion always good to
see you John Dickerson so you have
senator Scott there then you had senator
bob Corker say in words that I thought
think took many by surprise that he
doesn't think the president has
demonstrated the stability or the
competence to be successful in this job
this is a big deal why well guide two
things it's both who's saying the
remarks and the nature of them the first
is that senator corker is not some
hothead who's in the traditional kind of
usual suspects category who's always
criticizing the president of everything
he does
senator Scott's not in that category
either so it's rare for him to criticize
the president they've golf together but
also it's the nature of the critique
which is not just about the reaction of
the events of Charles Hill but it's a
broader critique about the president's
stability and the compatibility between
his natural instincts and the job that
he holds and whether it's possible for
him to fit those natural impulses into
that job and if if this isn't solved
said senator corker the country will be
in great pair are you hearing that
others share this view that are
wondering about stability they have
shared that view in terms of the
president's incompatibility with the
office but it's always been off the
record or they've said you know we hope
things change or maybe General Kelly as
chief of staff will help and so forth
and so on but this just come out and say
it in public and not just toss off a
remark this is obviously carefully
considered in and kind of a methodical
critique the president's isolation grows
he's now insulted more Republicans I
think this week than Democrats on his
Twitter feed even within his own White
House staff the isolation grows what
does that mean for the consequences for
the rest of his presidency can he stay
in office for the next three and a half
years
well absent some other event you've got
Republicans who would have to remove him
from office and while the president is
quite isolated as you point out and
that's gonna have a real impact on his
ability to get any legislation passed
there are a lot of people in the
Republican Party who believe he is the
victim of a pile-on by the media started
by the media and now joined by some
people and so there are some who say you
know there's a dangerous world out there
and while we find the behavior of the
president of Jack
in places a B and C we still he's still
the president they're still terrorists
there's still an Iran deal we don't like
career North Korea's out there we must
rally behind him and then there's a
second group that says you know we must
stay in the white house we must support
him because who knows what he'll do if
there aren't people there to check him
and you look at the polling a decisively
decisive majority of Republicans support
what he said about Charlottesville the
overwhelming majority of the Democrats
disagree with what he said so again the
issue politicized right it sorts to
where people were originally but that's
where somebody like senator corker
matters because he's breaking out of the
usual trajectory these things go in and
and that was what could over time shift
the view of a president but at the
moment they pre people are pretty much
sorting in to where he said is where you
staying let's talk about substance in
terms of the decision this weekend at
Camp David Afghanistan big deal is Marco
Brennan pointed out big deal and for two
reasons one there is the the big deal at
the center of the policy after 16 years
as America still have interests in
Afghanistan and is America willing to
commit itself a war-weary nation willing
to commit itself to Afghanistan but then
it's also that it's making the decision
within the advisors the president has
there are obviously some real conflicts
inside of his administration conflicts
within the minutes but the President
himself he has said in these arguments
or it's been reported why are we still
there on the other hand he's taking a
very strong line against terrorism so
this is a model for a complex decision
to be made by the president in his
administration and whether he can make
it effectively is one of the things
somebody like bob Corker worries about
I'm thinking John will have a lot to
discuss on Sunday that's right so Sunday
on Face the Nation John will speak with
Republican senator Tim Scott of South
Carolina and Democratic senator Tim
Kaine of Virginia looking forward to
that conversation that's Sunday here on
CBS all right
always lots to discuss is John Dickerson
nice job on Colbert last night play
there we go
good to see you